Mr Speaker every week whatever the topic
he stands there and pretends everything
is fine across the country and every
week he does so he reinforces just how
out of touch he is
nine thousand pounds hahaha nine
thousand pounds would take four years
they think it's funny that hope nine
about four years four years for the
average saver to save nine thousand
pounds or or to put it a different way
in terms the Prime Minister will
understand roughly the annual Bill to
heat his swimming pool
people
four more years of scrimping is a hammer
blow to their ambitions
and now he's kicking them when they're
down because his decision to scrap
housing targets is killing the dream of
home ownership for a generation why
doesn't admit he got it wrong and
reverse it
[Applause]
[Music]
I promise to put local people in control
of new housing and I'm proud that that's
what I delivered within six weeks of
becoming prime minister now he wants to
impose top-down housing targets he wants
to concrete over the green belt and ride
roughshod over local communities now
previously Mr Speaker he did say he's on
record and saying local people local
communities should have more power and
more control now he's u-turned just
another in a long list of broken
promises